from the front lines of the war in
Ukraine to a sharp rise in killings in
Latin America 2022 was another deadly
year for journalists and Al Jazeera was
not untouched our own correspondent
Serena Berkeley was shot dead by the
Israeli Army while on assignment in the
occupied West Bank in May worldwide at
least 67 journalists and media workers
were killed last year the highest number
since 2018 and then almost 50 percent
increase over 2021.
more than half of the killings occurred
in just three countries Ukraine Mexico
and Haiti each reported their highest
number of journalist deaths ever
18 of those killed were local reporters
who were murdered in retaliation for
their work covering politics crime and
Corruption
our correspondents now have this report
from some of the toughest places for
journalists to operate
[Applause]
2022 was a deadly year for journalists
around the world covering War conflicts
but also reporting on politics and
Corruption we've seen journalists
targeted for simply doing their jobs
well Ukraine is a dangerous place for
journalists they're often covering
stories very close to fighting all the
front lines but what we've seen in this
war since February 2022 is attacks can
happen anywhere and at any time now at
least 15 journalists were killed in
Ukraine since the War Began in February
amongst them an American and Lithuanian
or Frenchman but also ukrainians most
were killed in the first months of the
war but many others have also been
injured or even targeted in the course
of their work
in Latin America media workers are
facing daily challenges last year
British journalist Don Phillips was
murdered in the Brazilian Amazon
here in Mexico more journalists were
killed than any other country bar
Ukraine the committee to protect
journalists says that 13 in total died
that's more than they've ever recorded
in Mexico what are the reasons for that
well as you would expect the cartels and
the gangs that are very powerful in
parts of this country are attacking and
threatening journalists but also
authorities a federal government staff
says that 40 of the threats and attacks
against journalists actually came from
officials a lot of times those are local
ones it's local journalists here in the
Hinterlands of the country that are most
affected by this journalists have been
under attack over the last decade we've
seen press Freedom regress in the
Philippines we've we've now Shunk to at
the Press Freedom index where 147 out of
one EB countries around the world last
year radio and online commentator
Percival mabasa was gunned down inside a
gated bill College investigation
revealed that the former prison's chief
of the Philippines Gerald bantag was a
mastermind but it's not just the
killings ABS-CBN the country's largest
Deuce network still cannot broadcast on
free-to-air TV there is hope however
Maria ressa the Nobel prize winning
journalist she's been cleared of tax
evasion charges though she still faces
several cases in court and her news
Outlet Grappler still is in danger of
closure Israeli forces targeted and shot
Al Jazeera journalists while she was on
assignment in Janine she was a household
name a veteran journalist whose
colleagues looked up to and for that for
her killing to go without accountability
even though she was killed in front of
the camera just gives you an idea how
difficult it is and how high the price
is for journalists in Palestine just
last year 117 journalists were subjected
to attacks by Israeli military according
to the Palestinian journalists indicate
in 2023 doesn't look any better
let's bring in Jody Ginsburg who's
president of the committee to protect
journalists joins us now from New York
and Jody another Grim year indeed 67
journalists killed what conclusions do
you draw from the data gathered
what we can see is essentially the tip
of the iceberg the killing of a
journalist is the worst thing that you
could possibly imagine and it's
indicative I think of the sharply
deteriorate deteriorating environment
for journalism more generally we saw a
50 increase in journalists killed we're
also seeing a sharp uptick record number
of journalists imprisoned journalists
threatened everywhere around the world
not just Mexico Ukraine places where we
saw high levels of killings journalists
are under threat
and is the trend would you say overall
is it up over past years
the trend is uh in terms of press
Freedom declining and the trend in
threats against journalists are growing
we're seeing growing numbers of
journalists intimidated online
particularly women journalists and that
often leads those threats online often
lead to physical violence offline and
then potentially imprisonment and at the
very worst killings
so some journalists were killed doing
their jobs directly in war zones others
victim victims of targeted killings
including our own Israel what does the
kind of story that journalists are
covering when they're killed tell us
about
the trend and what's happening
it's really interesting so as you say
the highest number of journalists killed
last year were in Ukraine 15 journalists
killed in Ukraine you expect covering a
war zone to be a dangerous assignment
but what's really Stark about these
numbers is more than half the
journalists killed were not the majority
of journalists killed were not covering
War they were operating in nominally
countries that are nominally at peace
they're not in Conflict but increased
lawlessness and threats by government
officials and a culture of impunity
where these killings go unpunished is
all part of the pattern and often these
journalists are local journalists
they're covering local Affairs and and
what happens of course when they're not
covering those is there is no
information going out to those local
communities about all sorts of things
political corruption
business about health care about the
environment that's what happens when
you're effectively silence the
journalist population in a small
community right and more than half the
killings I think I'm right saying okay
in just three countries
that's right so 15 killings in Ukraine
13 in Mexico and seven in Haiti Latin
America is particularly alarming to us
we've seen increased lawlessness across
the region journalists trying to cover
that lawlessness of course incredibly
vulnerable they're vulnerable covering
political protests they're vulnerable
covering political corruption and
collusion and all too often we see a
failure by local authorities often
because they're implicated in that very
corruption to address and keep safe
those journalists or tackle their
murderers and bring them to account Jody
for you personally as president of the
committee to protect journalists this
must be pretty depressing there's an
annual report it certainly focuses the
mind but all it does is reveal this
terrible Trend that we've been talking
about and does it really make any
difference in the end
you're right it is depressing I'm a
journalist and I never thought when I
started as a journalist that I would be
witnessing journalists killed for
covering politics in large Capital
metropolitan cities or being threatened
for doing their jobs I think what gives
me hope is increasingly I think people
are beginning to understand the value
that journalists bring and the
importance of Journalism to society as a
whole I think there are things that we
can do we're working really hard to
ensure that there are effective
mechanisms to protect journalists as a
federal mechanism in Mexico we think
more could be done to strengthen that
with resources to effectively protect
journalists so though it is a depressing
picture I think there is hope for Change
and Improvement
all right Jay the important worker an
important report indeed at Jody Ginsburg
from the committee to protect
journalists thank you